hello i'm jonathan vanness you may know
me from queer eye on netflix getting
curious on netflix i don't know where
you know me from but i do know this my
new book love that story is out now and
we're going to do a little bit of q a
smr
for our first selection it's so hard to
whisper i'm gonna do it now though
filming queer riot oh my gosh i can't do
it anymore it's an incredible
opportunity to delve
into someone else's life and in every
episode i give myself over to each hero
and help in any way i can
i love my job and i also
love that the show allows me to be a
hairdresser a comedian and an overall
entertainer but as i've spent more time
in these different careers i've realized
that i can't stop and take a moment for
my personal life even if i'm going
through something incredibly hard when i
signed on to queer eye i became a beacon
of positivity and love and there are a
lot of times when i have to maintain
that strength even when i should
probably be taking a little time to
focus that positivity inward to let
myself mourn when a tragedy happens like
what happened to bug the second
i think what i've learned about grief
from exploring grief in this chapter and
then just like the various times that
i've dealt with grief in my life is that
there's no one way that we're all going
to handle grief and it's so individual
for whatever the thing that we're
grieving is for wherever we are in our
lives and i think it's important for us
to like release the judgment and release
the shame around how we grieve because
sometimes you just have to impulse adopt
like two kittens
and that's okay
for our second section
my imposter
what sneak up
oh my gosh i made it five words on me
most often while researching different
cities i was scheduled to perform it
i plan to talk about the venues i'd be
at find out what the comedy scene was
like there and incorporate a little
local flair into my set
but then i think about how many other
comedians had spent their whole lives
trying to do the same thing but never
got the chance at smaller venues where i
was booked alongside more established
comedians
i'd sometimes get paranoid that they
were giving serious attitude like who is
this
blink
oh who is this
unscripted nobody from queer eye he
doesn't deserve to be here
much in the way that i look at oksana
bayul for her gold medal nancy was
robbed and i don't care who knows it
thank you for coming to our q a smr with
me jonathan vanessa my book love that
story is available now at
jonathanvadness.combook
yay or wherever you get your books
[Music]